[Music]
you know we wanted to make a show that
was kind of harkening back to like
sitcoms that we liked growing up oh my
god oh my god we don't have noses sort
of fish out of water
aliens living amongst humans with all
their weird sci-fi tech and do Hickory
and get up to some pretty wacky
misadventures are you ready to do what
it takes you mean sex stuff that's
possible because they're aliens
you don't totally know their limits and
where they come from human standards
like the materialism the only thing that
matters is today we're getting a jet ski
and being a part of the problem it's
like a really fun Justin roiland II kind
of show like those designs are so royal
indie I don't know how else to describe
them he's got that loose rambling way he
finds it in the booth it's very
different than Rick and Morty it's a
little more lighthearted it's not as
nihilistic not as much of a mind [ __ ] I
think for the beginning we were like
this should be a show that's fun just be
cool like me boo-ki robes are not cool
just jealous of my swish it starts off
and it feels familiar
like a family style animated show let's
dig old [ __ ] I don't know some sort of
human code and then we take it to the
most insane places you could ever
imagine check this out Terry watch wait
gives you the old one-two sets hip with
the jab and then jab jab yanked down
your pants show your little penis in
front of your parents and your parents
are like I haven't seen that in a while
the idea of the entire world knows
they're there and doesn't really give a
[ __ ] go back to your home in the abyss
not all aliens are from the abit being
able to tell stories that are insane and
not have to worry about the military
coming in and people freaking out
completely change the way we could write
the show because we are following our
stupidest instincts we're letting them
just do the funny thing instead of the
logical thing it can be so dark and I'm
still laughing I did hate myself a
little bit for liking the show I'm like
come on you're a better person than this
by the way I got some heroin you guys
want to do heroin for some reason in
context it doesn't seem that bad but
when I say it out loud it just seems so
morbid or I'm baking cookies in here
does baby wanna lick my spoon my biggest
dream is I want people to watch the show
and just [ __ ] themselves from shock and
awe
I want all that was once in out
it's a hashtag that's all I want
[Music]